[Music]
so as some of you know threading the
needle is a great way to get very good
at butterfly and uh it can look amazing
in itself somebody wrote me recently to
ask how do you learn to do
it behind your
head and behind your
back now first off it's a great thing to
be able to learn because if you can
learn to thread the needle behind your
head and behind your back you're also
going to be very good at passing the PO
very close to each other which means all
of your butterfly stuff will look
amazing you won't lose your planes
behind your
body for behind the head it's actually
kind of easy uh this is the first real
trick if you just start in front of you
here and you slowly bend your planes
backwards bend them backwards threading
the needle th and you can kind of look
at first threading the needle down I
don't want to lean too far back and you
keep going and you keep going and you
look forwards you're threading the
needle behind your your head so you want
to learn to do that both
ways and you might take a few days but
that's really going to teach you how to
do it behind your head and once you're
doing that really goes low as you can
just feel what you're doing how you're
going right on top left on top right on
top left on top right on top left on top
right on top left on top or switch
rights on top lefts on top and you want
to get good at that
once you're good at
that and you can learn do it behind your
back just really notice that whatever
One's On Top is passing further from
your
feet and then you're going to switch and
the other one poof is further from your
feet and with a bunch of
practice boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom you'll be threading the needle
behind your back it might really take
some days um it did for me I could do it
like six seven times in a row and then
poof they'd hit but then eventually they
stopped hitting and once you've got that
you'll find you know you're going behind
the head behind the back and it'll all
just be a lot more effortless and
controlled cuz you really know where the
PO are behind your body so uh you know
find um find a cliff get some Po and
give it a try remember if you like uh if
you like the videos that I make just
like them on Facebook like them on
YouTube show me some love and uh and
I'll keep doing it
um if I had a wing suit I'd make a
really dramatic
exit but I don't so we'll just
[Music]
fade